accident de la route d'une première en
france avec l'introduction d'un délit de
consommation de drogue au volant en cas
d'accident un test de détection est mise
au point
le torchon brûle à la mairie de paris
entre le maire jean tibéri une partie sa
majorité conduite par jacques toubon qui
entend clarifier la gestion de la
municipalité et peut-être aller plus
loin face à la montée de la violence les
professeurs d'un lycée de goussainville
ans une procédure dallaire prévues par
la loi en cas de danger extrême les
vêtements de sport sont sortis des
stades pour descendre dans la rue c'est
une véritable mode plusieurs grandes
sociétés se disputent le marché 39
milliards de chiffre d'affaires en 97
c'est notre enquête de ce soir comment
repérer les victimes d'avalanches un
nouveau système très simple vient d'être
testé une pastille électronique
repérable sous plusieurs mètres de neige
madame monsieur bonsoir les accidents de
la route font encore plus de 8000 morts
par an sur les routes françaises
l'ambition du ministre des transports et
de les ramener à 4000 à l'échéance de
l'an 2002 pour ce faire un projet de loi
a été mise au point examiné aujourd'hui
par le sénat un projet qui devrait
aboutir à la création d'un délit de très
grande vitesse plus de 50 km au dessus
de ce qui est permis et puis la
nouveauté c'est aussi le contrôle et la
sanction pour les conducteurs circulant
sous l'emprise d'une drogue
une étude inédite montre que 16% que
même des accidents graves
les met en cause reportage à la nourrice
qui philippe lety maire ou femme
d'accidentés de la route
elle était cet après midi devant le
sénat pour faire pression sur les
parlementaires qui vont examiner le
projet de loi gayssot sur la sécurité
routière
pour elle la loi n'est pas assez sévère
la souffrance est elle quand on met son
bras sans cercueil c'est une destruction
pour des mois et des années
c'est inadmissible dans ce pays 23 fois
par jour on tue sur nos routes
l'ambition du gouvernement est de faire
passer le nombre de tués sur la route de
8000 à 4010 ya cinq ans parmi les
mesures envisagées l'instauration d'un
délit de grande vitesse en état de
récidive
par ailleurs un dépistage systématique
de l' usage de stupéfiants en cas
d'accident mortel est prévu dans le
dispositif gouvernemental
l'obligation de dépistage de la drogue
lors des accidents mortels
répondons un souci de sérieux d'une part
pour connaître et analyser le phénomène
est autre part pour étudier validé
mettre en place rationnellement avec le
secrétaire d'état à la santé et l'agencé
du médicament
le dispositif technique de prélèvement
et l'analyse qui aujourd'hui n'existe
pas selon une enquête récente 20% des
accidents graves seraient dus à des
conducteurs ayant pris des drogues
nous avons une positivité de l'ordre de
16% pour du cannabis 3 % pour l'héroïne
et ses dérivés et un demi pour cent pour
les dérivés de l'express
conçu par les allemands un appareil de
ce type aient déjà expérimenté aux états
unis en angleterre pour ce genre de
dépistage il est en cours d'homologation
en france ces résultats devront être
confirmés par analyse sanguine
la commission des lois du sénat propose
que soit établie une peine de deux ans
de prison et de 30 mille francs d'amendé
en cas de contrôle positif à la veille
des vacances scolaires de pâques une
nouvelle manifestation des enseignants
parents d'élèves élèves de seine saint
denis en région parisienne qui réclament
des moyens supplémentaires en hommes et
en matériel ils étaient encore il était
encore quelques centaines aujourd'hui
dans paris avec la crainte de voir leur
mouvement s'essouffler et insuffisamment
relayée par les syndicats c'est ce
qu'ils ont dans le même temps une
nouvelle affaire a éclaté dans le
département du val d'oise une partie des
professeurs d'un lycée de goussainville
ont décidé de se déclarer en procédure
d' alerte en application d'un décret de
1995 qui était surtout destiné à
l'origine à être utilisées en cas de
danger matériel comme le mauvais état
des locaux mais c'est pour alerter
l'opinion publique en raison de
violences récentes et inquiétant que les
professeurs y ont fait référence pour la
première fois jean bernard schmid la
dernier défi
dans un lycée où tout le monde a pu
constater la présence d'armes de toutes
sortes ou des batailles rangées ont eu
lieu ou là où l'intervention de la
police a évité de justesse une tragédie
des plus sanglantes
nous pensons que si l'on peut prévenir
le sang et le danger c'est notre devoir
de fonctionnaires et non pas d'attendre
que le pire arrive et pour ne pas
attendre plus longtemps
la moitié des professeurs du lycée
romain rolland de goussainville à cci
relais coup pas une grève mais une
procédure d' alerte une première en
france
l'application d'un décret de 95
concernant la protection des
fonctionnaires sur leur lieu de travail
les professeurs réagissait ainsi aux
affrontements entre élèves survenu dans
le lycée le 26 mars dernier
depuis il estime qu'aucune mesure
concrète n'a été prise certains élèves
eux comprennent les profs
même s'il pense aux examens c'est un peu
dommage pour les élèves mais je suis
d'accord avec ce et c'est normal et son
danger de mort donc ils ont droit de
faire ça mais les élèves sont un peu
comment dire ça ils sont
sopat changera la sopat chance le
proviseur du lycée ainsi qu'une partie
des parents d'élèves regrette l'attitude
des professeurs le rectorat quant à lui
affirme que l' usage de la procédure d'
alerte n'est pas justifié et annonce la
tenue d'une table ronde pour régler les
problèmes du lycée le feu couvait depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant cette fois ci
la bataille a lieu à découvert à
l'initiative de l'ancien ministre
jacques toubon un groupe de conseillers
municipaux de paris a décidé de croiser
le fer avec l'actuel maire jean tibéri
de tout sur fond de polémique sur la
gestion actuelle et la crainte pour la
droite de perdre la municipalité aux
prochaines élections véronique saint
olive jean-marc sur ça ils sont trente
conseillers municipaux rpr udf réuni
pour la première fois ce matin 30 élus
qui déclare la guerre à jean tiberi en
créant un nouveau groupe au sein de la
majorité municipale jacques toubon mène
le putsch et bernard pons président de
l'association des amis de jacques chirac
le suis il dénonce la gestion du maire
dont ils ont voté le budget le climat
des affaires et prétendent que seule une
nouvelle équipe pour affronter la gauche
aux prochaines élections jacques toubon
conseiller du président de la république
a quitté son bureau de l'elysée hier
tout semble confirmer que jacques chirac
n'approuve pas ce coup de force
le président la république n'était en
rien concerné par les questions qui
concernent la municipalité parisienne
nous n'avons nul besoin de par un ou
deux tuteurs jean tiberi désormais
minoritaires contre attaque brutalement
il retire aux adjoints dissidents leurs
délégations et revendique le soutien du
président de la république président de
la république d'une part je soutiens
totalement
il me l'a confirmé et il condamne
totalement cette manoeuvre inacceptable
c'est une ambition personnelle de
monsieur toubon qui n'a jamais accepté
je sois maire de paris et il voudrait
l'est
bien il ne le sera pas et moi je reste
et je resterai maire de paris à gauche
on compte les points avec un seul
discours tous dans le même panier les
appétits et les rancoeurs les divisent
et en même temps aux yeux des parisiens
je pense que il ya conscience que leur
gestion commune de paris depuis 21 ans
pouvoir confisqué à l'hôtel de ville les
disqualifie tous
mais derrière la majorité municipale
explosé sur fond de rumeurs et d'échecs
électoraux
c'est tout le système mis en place par
jacques chirac lui même qui se fissurent
la crise de l'hôtel de ville de paris
pourrait avoir des conséquences
incalculables dans le feuilleton des
élections de présidents de conseils
régionaux il ne faut pas louper un seul
épisode faute de quoi on a bien du mal à
suivre aujourd'hui à dijon donc après
deux tours de scrutin où il ne s'était
pas présenté jean pierre soisson
apparentée udf qui avait démissionné une
première fois la semaine dernière a
finalement décidé de se représenter au
troisième tour et il a été élu devançant
d'une voix le candidat socialiste avec
l'apport de quelques voix du front
national
et cette fois ci dit il je ne
démissionnerai pas reportage michaël
darmon grégoire aussi l' ambiance d'une
première séance de travail à la région
bourgogne depuis cinquante minutes jean
pierre soisson est de nouveau élu
président de la région avec une partie
des voix du front national
il tente de faire élire son exécutif
de gauche n'accepte pas le maintien de
jean pierre soisson lui sourit sûr de
son père jean pierre soisson si des
maximes mais c'est bien là rythme et si
qui l'a emporté retour sur une élection
candidat pour la première fois au
troisième tour il obtient 27 voix contre
26 pour la gauche il y aura une
abstention trois boîtes blanc et une
surprise et cette enveloppe vide va
fournir un jean pierre soisson un alibi
il considère qu'il s'agit là d'une
défection de la gauche une gauche qui a
d'ailleurs reçu deux voix du front
national
donc jean pierre soisson a la conscience
tranquille
je leur ai peut-être tout le monde a eu
les voix des voies du tram à chaumont et
il est l'un verserait plus parfaitement
se produire je ne vois pas les raisons
dans lesquelles pour cette raison je
serai conduit à dépressionnaire entre la
droite et la gauche c'est donc la guerre
des calculettes avec le fn en arbitre
tout le raisonnement qui consiste à dire
nous n'y avait que 23 bulletins de la
gauche plurielle c'est pour essayer de
faire passer la manipulation par rapport
au vote du front national et ça je dis
ce n'est pas acceptable c'est facile à
prouver
à ma connaissance il n'y a pas de
président de gauche au conseil de
bourgogne mission accomplie et la séance
entrants ont réparti censés voter à
gauche si bien qu'à droite le front
national permet donc à jean pierre
soisson de se disculper et de rester
cette fois président d'une région qui
sera bien difficile à gouverner
rappel la nuit dernière au conseil
régional de midi pyrénées cette fois ci
à toulouse c'est le socialiste martin
malvy qui a finalement été élue au
détriment du candidat rpr udf marc censi
que dernier tour a décidé de ne pas se
représenter
le ministère de l'intérieur a fait
connaître aujourd'hui le dernier bilan
de l'opération régularisation des
sans-papiers 41500 régularisation pour
39 1500 dossiers refusés le ton monte
entre jean pierre chevènement qui se
sent fort du soutien du premier ministre
et une partie de sa majorité vers parti
communiste qui estime que sa politique
est trop restrictive débat également
avec certaines autorités religieuses
avec l'évêque de bobigny après que des
dizaines de sans-papiers se soit
installé dans plusieurs lieux de culte
reportage
olivier galzi et angie qui l'attend est
toujours les mêmes slogans
par peur d'être expulsé les sans papiers
de bobigny ont quitté pour quelques
heures le régler
l'église et son évêque coupable aux yeux
du ministre de l'intérieur coupable de
les avoir accueillis
si un jour il y a en france un
gouvernement hégémonie zh et par
l'extrême droite
lévesque en rendra compte au jugement
dernier cette phrase prononcée hier par
jean pierre chevènement n'a pas laissé
indifférents les sans papiers de bobigny
salir sa part sa part brice ton
gouvernement a testé 2 pour vous comme
ça alexa papier directement visés les
autorités cléricales honte elle aussi
répondu au ministre de l'intérieur
moi j'ai une parole de l'évangile qui me
vient tout de suite à l'esprit en
entendant monsieur chevènement
c'est la parole qui nous sera posée au
moment du jugement j'étais un étranger
est-ce que tu m'a accueilli et c'est
donc le rôle de l'église n'ont pas de
résoudre les problèmes qui sont posés
par les sans papiers mais de dire
attention ces personnes ont une dignité
qui doit être respecté cet après midi
c'est donc sur la gestion de cette
nouvelle polémique jean pierre
chevènement a dû s'expliquer et tenter
de convaincre une majorité plurielle de
plus en plus divisés sur cette question
de l'immigration vous en tenir
jean pierre chevènement qui a reçu le
soutien du premier secrétaire du ps
françois hollande qui n'a pas nié ses
divergences avec ses alliés mais at il
ajouté la politique de l'immigration qui
s'applique est bien celle du parti
socialiste et le premier ministre en
personne devrait le confirmer demain à
l'assemblée nationale la disparition à
l'âge de 86 ans d'une des grandes
figures de la politique en corse jean
paul de rocca serra élu rpr depuis 1962
il a terminé sa carrière à la tête de
l'assemblée territoriale il était
l'archétype du politicien corse à la
tête d'une famille à laquelle beaucoup
de vet énormément michele finn jacques
cardoze les drapeaux de la mairie de
porto-vecchio sont en berne à jean paul
de rocca serre s'est éteint hier soir le
nom sur un jour
le matin je n'ai pas dessus de phoques à
celle ci nous impose
j'avais tout dit pour moi c'était le
père de porter est urbain on l'appelait
le renard argenté sa carrière politique
a commencé sous la quatrième république
en 1950 il est élu à la mairie de
porto-vecchio puis réélu pendant un demi
siècle parfois avec les voies nationales
en 1962 il s'installe sur les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale en 84 c'est
l'assemblée de corse qui lui offre le
fauteuil de président son fils camille
était le conseiller général
on appelle cela le clan tous les rouages
de la politique locale entre les mains
d'une même famille pour moi le clan chez
les traditions chez valeur nos valeurs à
nous corps ch
c'est ça je vous appelez le clan à bord
est horrible clan chez rétrograde
je suis en paix le développement d'accor
je suis à m me cherches l'habilité et on
peut être emporté hors du lion en
franche et celui qui succède à jean paul
de rocca serra l'assemblée nationale et
l'homme de notre plan rolland franchise
ea propriétaire de cercles de jeux
parisiens frère de l'ancien empereur des
jeux marcel franchise ea a battu au
début des années 80 à paris l'ancien
président et à faire du conseil général
de l'essonne et xavier dugoin devant le
tribunal correctionnel on lui reproche
plusieurs faux administratifs et des
détournements de fonds publics à usage
personnel et à celui de sa famille
xavier dugoin conteste les faits qui lui
sont reprochés olivier caroff olivier
robert
xavier dugoin peut être fier de son
épouse
harcelé de questions sur les 20 mille
francs qu'elle touchait chaque mois du
conseil général de l'essonne
elle a rappelé au tribunal tout ce
qu'elle avait fait pour le département
entre 93 et 95 représentait son mari à
une fête de noël l'accompagner à deux
foires aux légumes recevoir une
représentantes d'associations s'occuper
d'une partie du courrier le parquet
d'evry lui a trouvé un autre
qualificatif pour ce travail
détournement de fonds publics
mais ce n'est pas la seule affaire qui
vaille aujourd'hui un procès à l'ancien
président rpr du conseil général de
l'essonne
sa femme de ménage elle aussi été
salariées par le département
départements qui financent et en prime
certains voyages privés de la famille
dubois
on est choqué par des apparences les
billets d'avion c'est tout aussi simple
avant qu'il y ait une information
judiciaire savait qu'il avait une tête
anodine a été fait il a remboursé la
totalité de ce qu'ils devaient quant à
l'emploi de sa femme
je crois que les témoignages ont été
nombreux l'accusation a fait citer
personne à quelques mètres du tribunal
l'ancien fief de xavier dugoin avec
l'élection d'un nouveau président le
conseil général a fait ses comptes et
décidé de porter plainte
nous sommes face à une pratique qui est
une pratique manifestement de confusion
entre les besoins privés et les fonds
publics pour un montant total de celui
que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure c'est à
dire pour un montant total d'environ un
million et demi sur deux ans un procès
qui pourrait être le premier d'une
longue série pour xavier dugoin c'est en
tout cas ce que lui a promis le
procureur il y actuellement une dizaine
d' enquêtes en cours sur les affaires du
conseil général l'ancien chef de la
cellule antiterroriste de l'elysée
françois de françois mitterrand
christian prouteau va se retrouver
devant le tribunal correctionnel
en marge de la sphère des écoutes
téléphoniques il est accusé de recel de
documents secrets ayant trait à la
défense nationale christian poteau
faisait déjà l'objet d'une mise en
examen dans le cadre plus global de
cette affaire dans le cadre de
l'application à venir de la loi sur les
35 heures par semaine les propriétaires
de grands magasins de centre ville ont
dénoncé la convention collective des
personnels pour protester contre cette
démarche plusieurs centaines de salariés
ont défilé ce matin dans paris sébastien
guibert alain location
c'est dans leur propre région que les
salariés grévistes des galeries
lafayette ont débuté leurs
manifestations ce matin mot d'ordre
refuse l annualisation du temps de
travail que l'union patronale des grands
magasins souhaite appliquer avec les 35
heures à trois semaines la france arrête
un mois qu'on revienne pour transmettre
moi j'ai un bébé et puis bon j'estime
que j'ai bataillé les dimanches il y a
dix jours l'union patronale a dénoncé la
convention collective des quarante mille
salariés du secteur
objectif faire travailler cadres et
employés plus ou moins longtemps chaque
semaine ou chaque jour selon les besoins
avec à la fin de l'année une moyenne est
fictive de 35 heures hebdomadaires
les horaires des magasins ils sont pas
déterminées par les patrons ils sont en
réalité déterminé par les clients si
quentin clients viennent on répond pas
vous savez c est en fait qui est visé
c'est l'ensemble des salariés du
commerce pour une extension d ouverture
le soir d extension du travail le
dimanche
à travers ça l'exploitation de plus en
plus du travail et la direction lundi
les salariés les négociations pour une
nouvelle convention collective ne font
donc que commencer
syndicats et patrons ont entre 15 et 20
mois pour aboutir
l'europe en marche avec l'arrivée de
l'euro la banque de france va changer de
statut avant le 30 avril pour transférer
une partie de ses prérogatives à la
banque centrale européenne pour le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
la france gardera tout de même une bonne
part de sa souveraineté puisque ce sont
les ministres qui trancheront en
définitive sur les grands problèmes pour
autant les alliés du ps les verts le
parti communiste conteste cet accord
ainsi que charles pasqua qui a annoncé
qu'il voterait contre ce transfert de
souveraineté la plus grande société de
services financiers vient de naître aux
états unis avec la fusion de la city
corp et du trailer groupe sous le nom de
citigroup qui va totaliser plus de 100
millions de clients dans plus de 100
pays dans le monde
il suffit de se promener dans les rues
pour se rendre compte qu aujourd'hui les
vêtements de sport ne sont plus réservés
à la seule pratique c'est un formidable
marché qui se développe 39 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires l'an dernier en
france et une bataille serrée entre
les grands de la production et de la
distribution qui ont installé leurs
propres magasins
c'est notre enquête de ce soir sophie
jouve question finale parce que l'on
pratique de plus en plus d'activités
parce que les baskets se cherchent à la
ville le marché du sport s'envole 39
milliards de francs de chiffre
d'affaires en france est un leader
incontestable des calculs basés à lille
ce géant et distributeurs certes mais
producteurs avant tout et ses créateurs
ne sont pas choisis au hasard
le critère d'embauché strictes tous sont
passionnés de sport tout ce sont les
premiers utilisateurs de leurs produits
randonneurs jérôme s'occupe des sacs à
dos
fils de jockey stéphane juifs et des
selles il a même quitté hermès pour des
camions voie les seniors une davis et on
a toujours deux clients le cheval et le
cavalier
donc il faut le concours du cheval mais
pas de cette façon et le clavier qui
savent lire ci dessus non que ces deux
critères sont très importants du vélo à
la chaussure décathlon a aujourd'hui un
réel savoir faire technique mais sa
botte secrète la voici
aussitôt terminée le prototype est testé
à la vente de l'atelier au magasin il
n'y a qu'une porte à franchir un petit
tour de piste essentielle car la
production série en dépendra si le
client nous fait savoir qu'en fait ça ne
correspond pas du tout à ses souhaits
l'expérience s'arrêtera là et on passera
à autre chose la recette fait mouche
décathlon dans aujourd'hui la moitié de
ses produits sous son nom en
privilégiant production française et
petits prix face à ce raz de marée les
concurrents d'abord tétanisés passe à la
contre-offensive taille des magasins
gestion des stocks politique de marques
propres à chacun sa stratégie go sport
lui joue toujours la carte de la marque
le marché en fait devient de plus en
plus vaste avec une gamme de plus en
plus large
donc le fauteuil un terreau sportif ça
nous amène parfois faire le grand écart
entre les produits donc sur un produit
comme comme un ballon coupe du monde on
trouve nos premiers prix à 69 francs sur
un ballon on va dire type et loisirs et
on monte on monte en gamme sur les
produits donc de marque pour arriver au
ballon officiel de la coupe du monde qui
est un produit à près de 500 francs qui
est un ballon de compétition avec
effectivement un usage totalement
différent que le premier prix une et à
force de ne pas choisir les plus gros
poissons risquent de s'échapper
les 15 25 ans obsédé par les grands noms
du sport etc ce créneau là qu'une
nouvelle chaîne made in sport bien
occupé avec la force de frappe du groupe
pinault printemps derrière lui on peut
ici devenir michael jordan ou eric
cantona
la star est débité en produits
vous avez par exemple à chaque fois donc
le maillot le ballon de l'équipe vous
avez une petite fiche explicative qui
est l'entraîneur le palmarès de l'équipe
donc les joueurs vont pouvoir être dans
com présente dans le magasin les gens
vont comme s'ils étaient en relation
avec eux comme s'ils pouvaient
identifier des artistes mise en scène
pour séduire le grand public
savage à tous les gens qui aiment le
sport confond qui définissent des
émotions qui inévitablement on se
retrouve devant le petit écran qui tue
se retrouve complètement en osmose avec
le spectacle du sport et là on va
retrouver tous les ingrédients qu'on
retrouve en général d'un spectacle du
sport avec des produits qu'ils
prolongent l'émotion qui est né de ce
spectacle et à en juger par la ferveur
qui entoure la ferrari de schumacher
on ne peut que douter que le sport à ces
temples ces marchands et déjà ces
intégristes l'actualité internationale
depuis le mois de septembre dernier la
terre n'a jamais vraiment cessé de
trembler en italie centrale au point que
bon nombre d'habitants ont décidé de
s'installer durablement dans le
provisoire par crainte de réintégrer
leur domicile rome à 25 dimanche 18h
le staff de goual de tadine or en ombrie
un joueur tire un coup franc
et soudain la terre tremble panique
générale une forte secousse aussi fort
pratiquement que la première celle du 26
septembre six mois et demi de
tremblement de terre continue des
milliers de secousses près de 10000
toujours puissants le nouveau coupe
dimanche a complètement vidé golgotha
dino de ses 15000 habitants volets clos
et chiens errants
les gens ont repris le chemin des tentes
et des caravanes ils préfèrent même
dormir dans les voitures du provisoire
j'ai ma maison ici aquagym et habitat en
principe les par dessus tout il y a la
peur je suis terrorisée à terré chez le
coeur ici
les plus fortunés finalement sont ceux
dont les maisons ont déjà été détruites
ils ont été relogés pour la plupart dans
ces villages de préfabriqués pas
vraiment gay bien sûr mais au moins il y
à la sécurité les autres trous chacun
leurs solutions parfois un peu bizarre
j'habite ici parce que là j'ai peur la
chambre et tous mes jeux de rang bas
parce que là au moins je peux m'enfuir
ici grande qu'au moindre bruit tout le
monde est dehors
quand je dois aller aux toilettes plat
derrière je laisse la porte ouverte
ainsi au moindre bruit je peux m'enfuir
qu'importe si la maison paraît plus
solide que la cabane qu une pichenette
semble pouvoir emporter
personne ne fera téléphoner madame
depuis l'intérieur de la maison
l'irrationnel règne en maître en brie
les autorités le savent bien qui chaque
soir installe d'un dortoir de 190 lits
sous cette structure gonflable à 20
heures il est vide
à 22 heures il se remplit de tous ceux
qui croyaient avoir le courage de dormir
à la maison et qui finalement viennent
ici chercher le sommeil du juste
voyant la république qui a terminé ce
soir son voyage en bosnie une journée
consacrée au souvenir des soldats
français tués pendant les quatre années
de guerre puis un discours également sur
la nécessaire réconciliation des
différentes communautés qui composent le
pays reportage philippe harrouard
jacques gregor le pont de verbania le 27
mai 1995 il tombe par surprise aux mains
des serbes
le jour même des soldats français
lancent l'assaut et le reprenne
accompagné de deux d'entre eux le
président chirac revis l'opération qui
fait deux morts côté français les
combats réellement duré un peu plus de
20 minutes et
les accrochages très violent maintenant
les combats en lui-même on dort et plus
d'une heure et demie sur la position à
sarajevo le chef de l'état se rend sur
les lieux symboliques de la guerre le
marché de markale et où un obus tiré le
5 février 94 battu et 66 livre rencontre
avec les dirigeants musulmans croates et
serbes
les ennemis d'hier peine à bâtir en
commun la bosnie d'aujourd'hui alors
jacques chirac lance un appel aux plus
jeunes qui feront la bosnie de demain ne
cédez pas au découragement et au
renoncement
croyez en vous même en votre pénis en
son avenir
croyez en la fraternité et puis visite
en forme d'hommage 3500 soldats français
de la sport basé à mostar chargé de
veiller avec d'autres aux accords de
paix trente cinq mille militaires de 36
pays composent la force multinationale
la sport devait terminer son mandat en
juin prochain
il est prolongé sans limite de temps ce
qui montre à l'évidence que l'on
considère les accords de paix en bosnie
comme très très fragile
un nouvel espoir dans le domaine de la
santé dans la lutte contre le cancer du
sein
une étude américaine révèle qu'un
médicament pris de manière préventive
pourrait réduire de moitié les risques
de développer ce type de cancer pour
autant l'optimisme doit être mesuré dans
la mesure où ce médicament ne devrait
être administré qu'à les femmes
particulièrement exposé les risques
d'effets secondaires et tente important
jean daniel flaysakier bernard connes
ce médicament le tamoxifène va-t-il
empêcher la survenue d'un certain nombre
de cancers du sein une étude menée sur
13 une femme aux états unis peut a
priori le laisser penser
ces femmes qui était en pleine santé
avait tué au moins un cas de cancer du
sein dans leur famille ou bien un risque
héréditaire élevé ou encore des lésions
a priori bénigne mais pouvant évoluer
vers un cancer
les volontaires ont été répartis en deux
groupes
au bout de quatre ans le nombre de
nouveaux cas de cancer étaient
pratiquement divisé par deux dans le
groupe recevant le tamoxifène ce
pourrait être une bonne nouvelle
d'autant qu'en plus de la diminution des
cancers du sein il ya eu moins de
fracture sans doute parce que le
tamoxifène limite les risques
d'ostéoporose
mais les effets indésirables du
tamoxifène sont loin d'être négligeables
premier d'entre eux l'augmentation du
nombre des cancers de l'utérus 0.5 pour
cent des femmes traitées en ont été
victimes
et puis il ya eu trois fois plus de
phlébite et d'embolie chez les femmes
recevant ce médicament pour les
spécialistes le produit ne doit pas être
donnée avant la ménopause car il peut
avoir un effet nocif sur le verre et le
sein après la ménopause
la prudence reste de mise l'étude se
confirme et si le rapport bénéfice /
risque et dans le sens favorable
on peut envisager de la donner aux
femmes ménopausées qui ont un risque
augmenté de cancer du sein peut-être
parce qu'il ya une histoire familiale ou
partielle des antécédents de biopsies
pour lésions mammaires
mais dans le cadre d'études fait par des
centres spécialisés
la prescription du tamoxifène ne pourra
pas se faire à la légère les médecins
devront pour chaque femme évaluer les
avantages et les inconvénients et mettre
en place une surveillance appropriée
quinze jours à peine après sa naissance
le premier veau cloné en france peut
nommer marguerite est mort l'animal
s'est blessé dans l'enclos il avait été
placé mans accidentelle donc à la veille
des vacances de pâques et des derniers
séjours aux sports d'hiver un exercice
de recherche de victimes d'avalanche
était organisée à cauterets dans les
hautes-pyrénées les sauveteurs testait
un système de sécurité passif une
pastille électronique reportage
christophe la rocca olivier combe
repose sur une technique déjà ancienne
mais peu répandue ces petites plaques
métalliques ne pèse que quelques grammes
elle ne nécessite aucune pile pour
fonctionner dès la saison prochaine
on les trouvera largement incorporé aux
vêtements de ski ou directement dans le
commerce pour moins de 100 francs
le but assurer une meilleure sécurité
dans le périmètre les stations car en
cas d'avalanche ce détecteur une sorte
de radar permet de retrouver les
victimes en quelques secondes sa
puissance lui permettrait même
d'effectuer des repérages à bord
d'hélicoptères volant à quelques mètres
du sol voilà pour les stations il s'agit
avant tout de se prémunir contre des
coulées de neige provoquées par des
skieurs hors-piste inconscient mais de
plus en plus nombreux d'autre part le
plus et c'est que l utilisateur qui par
méconnaissance du site ou qui va faire
quelque chose de dangereux peut être
pris dans une avalanche
c'est pas parce qu'il a commis une
imprudence qu'on ne doit pas le lui
donner toutes les chances d'être d'être
recherché trouver
l'efficacité du système a été démontré
au cours de nombreux exercices comme ici
à cauterets la majorité des stations
devraient être équipés dès l'an prochain
avec deux risques apporté un faux
sentiment de sécurité aux casse cou mais
aussi offrir de randonnée car le système
est efficace qu aux abords immédiats des
stations lorsque on a sur le domaine
skiable nous font intervenir dans le
quart d'heure donc là c'est parfaitement
valable en revanche ans pour le ski de
randonnée
il nous faut utiliser l'hélicoptère et
les temps de réaction entre l' alerte le
départ l'hélicoptère et cetera et cetera
sont beaucoup plus longs puisque c'est
de l'ordre de 45 minutes
la seule solution pour les randonneurs
reste donc le système
harvin un émetteur récepteur que tous
ces adeptes d' aventure devrait porter
plus cher 1500 francs par personne lui
seul permet aux rescapés d'une avalanche
de porter immédiatement secours à leurs
camarades
car après un quart d'heure l'espérance
de vie d ancenis chute d'une façon
impressionnante
les musulmans du monde entier fêtent
aujourd'hui l'aïd el-kébir la fête du
sacrifice la tradition ancestrale
voulait que l'on abatte un mouton chez
soi en famille les conditions de la vie
moderne en ville notamment font évoluer
cette tradition et s'est aussi d'une
certaine forme d'intégration marque
maisonneuve
dida dans l'islam l'aïd el kebir est un
symbole la soumission totale du croyant
à dieu aussitôt après la prière comme
tous les musulmans
khadija va acheter le mouton c'est une
tradition mais pas une obligation
religieuse d'abattre soi-même l'animal
alors elle va chez le boucher
comme tout le monde en france
aujourd'hui la fête du mont corse la
fête de l'aïd les gens comme nous qui
viennent le chercher
le boucher lui fait sa meilleure recette
le jour du mouton au coeur de paris à
les abattre de moutons pour les
musulmans français c'est plus facile
d'aller à la boucherie à côté de chez
eux qu à l'abattoir et un mouton entier
c'est cher mille francs pour avoir un
label halal
le label religieux officiel le mouton on
doit être abattue selon le rituel peu
d'abattoirs le pratiquer en france nous
avons saisi les autorités préfectorales
pour leur demander de réfléchir à dit si
tu pourquoi pas a dit site provisoire
mais sous le contrôle des services
vétérinaires et qui garantissent un la
santé et qui garantissent aussi que les
musulmans tuent leurs bêtes dans la
dignité
impossible de tueries soi même le mouton
c'est hors la loi je suis musulman donc
tous les ans mes parents
on était gorgé moutain battu un bon
temps ça s'est jamais fait dans un
placard
pour khadija la fête du mouton c'est la
fête du partage alors pour être comme
elle dit une bonne musulmane
elle milite dans une association
humanitaire la chorba pour tous
elle distribue le couscous à tous ceux
qui sont dans la rue ce soir la
découverte maintenant de l'infiniment
petit avec cette caméra destinée à
explorer la matière jusqu'au fond d'une
dent d'un tronc d'arbre ou encore d'un
guidon de vélo vous allez voir tout ce
que vous ne verrez jamais d'ailleurs à
l'oeil nu ni même au microscope
jean-claude allanic christ au final à
l'oeil nu
rien d'autre qu'une simple dents de
sagesse ayant appartenu un homme d'une
vingtaine d'années une plongée
fantastique dans la matière c'est à la
cité des sciences voyage extraordinaire
au delà des apparences à l'intérieur des
objets et des matériaux les plus
familiers et les plus banales comme ici
une dent de sagesse
souleymane voici le chemin invisible à
nos yeux qu'empruntent les bactéries une
véritable voie royale pour les caries
dans un univers chaotique de cristaux et
de molécules
pour réaliser cette prouesse
technologique des normes microscope
électronique et une dent découpé en
minuscule lamelles de 50 nanomètres
d'épaisseur 50 milliardième de mm le
résultat un zoom impressionnant et des
scènes d'une étrange beauté
je crois qu'à part les spécialistes on
n'a pas une idée très claire de ce qui a
derrière la surface des choses donc on a
voulu sortir ces images et laboratoires
et les donner à voir au grand public un
paysage de ligne brisé un flanc de
montagne ou relief en terrasse nous
sommes au coeur une bougie de voiture
ces marches géantes que vous apercevez
ce sont des cassures dans la lumineuse
sont elles qui vont donner son aspect
anguleux à la céramique de la bougie en
quelques minutes le lan voyage de la
caméra virtuelle va nous conduire au
bout de l infiniment petit une diagonale
c'est la soudure entre deux grinda
lumine et après un grossissement de
plusieurs millions de fois nous avons
atteint les limites de l'invisible aux
portes des atomes
la soirée des molières hier soir sur
france 2 les récompenses du théâtre
meilleur comédien michel bouquet pour
son interprétation dans les côtelettes
peu aux côtés de philippe noiret et puis
ensuite la meilleure comédienne
dominique blanc dans maison de poupée et
les grands vainqueurs ont été la troupe
du spectacle andré le magnifique au
théâtre tristan bernard à paris depuis
la comédie française aussi pour ses
nouvelles fourberies de scapin le
mondial du vent c'est le titre des
rencontres sportives qui ont lieu à port
leucate dans l'aude
ils sont présentés tous les sports
nautiques ou terrestre qui utilisent le
vent chaque année on y découvre de
nouvelles disciplines qui seront
pratiqués sur les plages pendant l'été
véronique ghiglione françoise maison
l'avantagent avec le char à cerf-volant
c'est que même quand la voile est dans
le sac
il est facilement transportable
sébastien est un mordu de cerfs-volants
il a commencé il ya quatre ans par se
faire tracter sur un matelas pneumatique
puis il a adopté le char un peu plus
sportif en char à cerf-volant on peut
bouger la voile et la mettre partout
dans le ciel donc pas réglé son vent
tandis qu'un char à voile à voile elle
est fixée pas plu aux contraintes quoi
le char à cerf-volant vient de nouvelle
zélande tout nouveau en france avec 3000
initiés et pas encore de véritables
enseignements pour environ 5000 francs
on a tout l'équipement et des les cinq
premiers mètres par grands vents ont
dépassé 80 km heure le cerf-volant
traditionnels
mais quelque chose d'esthétique mais à
mon avis un petit peu passif
si on a envie de glisser et envie
d'aller chercher des sensations on
cherche le mouvement la glisse une
petite planche sur l'eau et une aile de
tissus c'est le fly surf discipline
encore toute assez confidentielle avec
une centaine d'adeptes en france
beaucoup plus vivante paraît-il que la
planche à voile très physique
apparemment on a le harnais donc on est
accroché au cerf-volant ont pas tous
dans les bras et l'a planté très légère
tout est très léger comme on est tiré
vers le haut on n'a pas beaucoup de
frottement dans l'eau à la taille de la
planche permet il est vrai certaines
acrobaties mais cet été devant un public
attentif pratiques et les avec
modération
voile avant de nous quitter le rappel
des principaux titres de l'actualité de
ce jour d'abord accidents de la route
une première en france avec
l'introduction d'un délit de
consommation de drogue au volant cas
d'accident un test de détection a été
mise au point
puis le torchon brûle à la mairie de
paris entre le maire jean tibéri une
partie de sa majorité conduite par
jacques toubon qui entend clarifier la
gestion de la municipalité jean tiberi
lui n'entend pas démissionner ce soir le
paiement de la république a déclaré
qu'il n'avait pas l'intention de se
mêler de ces jeux politiques locaux
voilà la météo dans un instant sophie
davant 20h50 la deuxième partie de votre
film tv une voix en or avec ginette reno
22h40 diva le film de jean jacques
beineix avec richard bohringer notamment
demain matin 7 heures 5 ans dans les 4
vérités françoise laborde recevra
monsieur hervé 2 chaque voilà je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur ma
prochaine
bonsoir à tous